On Sunday, June 22nd, a brutal massacre
unfolded inside a church in Syria.
Muslim terrorists murdered 25
Christians, mostly women and children,
and wounded nearly 100 more during a
sacred worship service. According to
eyewitnesses, at least two armed men
stormed the Marlas Greek Orthodox Church
in Damascus during mass as some 350
worshippers were gathered in prayer and
indiscriminately opened fire, turning
the sanctuary into a scene of chaos and
carnage. Then one of them detonated his
explosive belt inside the church,
amplifying the devastation. A relief
worker who arrived soon after the attack
described the harrowing scene. "When we
got to the church," he said, "we found
the doorway filled with body parts.
Photographs from the site revealed
charred and blood splattered floors with
walls peppered by deadly shrapnel. I've
seen such images before. The horror is
impossible to describe. As devastating
as this latest Islamic terror attack on
a Christian church is, the response from
the international community has been at
best muted. So, here's my burning
question of the day. Why is this
atrocity not enough to rouse the United
Nations and other international bodies
to take notice and speak out the way
they always do when Muslims suffer
violence at the hands of non-Muslims?
For example, two years ago, the United
Nations boldly declared March 15th the
International Day to Combat
Islamophobia. What triggered this strong
and public move? Simple. On March 15th,
2019, an Australian gunman named Brenton
Tarant stormed two mosques in Christ
Church, New Zealand, killing 51 Muslim
worshippers and injuring 40 others.
Hence my question. If one horrific
attack on a mosque was enough for the UN
to institutionalize a global day of
remembrance and awareness, what about
the countless and often far deadlier
Muslim attacks on non-Muslim places of
worship? Why have these countless
massacres of Christians in their
churches failed to spark a similar
global outcry? To be clear, the Damascus
church attack is not some isolated
aberration. Indeed, to grasp the scale
and severity of this ongoing tragedy,
here is a sobering list of fatal Muslim
attacks on Christian churches in recent
years, organized by numbers of
casualties. Brace yourself.
Sri Lanka. On Easter Sunday 2019, a
Muslim extremist detonated bombs at
three churches and three hotels, killing
359 people, mostly Christians, and
injuring over 500. Pakistan. After
Easter services in 2016, Islamic
terrorists bombed a park crowded with
Christians. More than 70 were killed,
again, mostly women and children. One
witness recounted, quote, "There was
human flesh on the walls of our house."
Democratic Republic of Congo. In
February 2025, Muslim militants of the
Allied Democratic Forces forced 70
Christians to march inside a church,
then tied and brutally decapitated all
of them. Iraq, October 31, 2011.
Mirroring the recent Syrian attack,
Muslims stored a Baghdad church during
worship, firing indiscriminately and
detonating suicide vests, killing nearly
60 Christians, including women,
children, and infants. Nigeria again. On
Easter Sunday 2012, Muslim terrorists
bombed two churches, killing more than
50 and injuring many more. Nigeria
again. On Pentecost Sunday 2022, Muslim
gunmen opened fire on a crowded church,
killing over 50 and wounding dozens.
Egypt. On Palm Sunday 2017, Muslim
terrorists bombed two pack churches,
killing at least 45 and injuring over
100 Christians. Nigeria again. On
Christmas Day 2011, Muslim terrorists
shot up and bombed three churches,
killing 37 and injuring nearly 57
Christians. Egypt again. December 11th,
2016, Muslim suicide bombers attacked
two churches, killing 29 and injuring 47
Christians. Bkina Faso, August 25, 2024,
Muslim militants slit the throats of 26
Christians inside a church. Russia, June
23, 2024. On a Sunday, Muslim terrorists
launched attacks on multiple churches
and synagogues in Dagiststan, killing at
least 21 and wounding dozens. Among the
victims was the elderly Orthodox priest
Nikolai Kotalenov, who had his throat
slit. One church was also set ablaze.
Nigeria again, April 20, 2012. Muslim
gunman slaughter 20 Christians during
Sunday worship inside their church.
Democratic Republic of Congo, January
15, 2023. Muslim extremists bomb a
church during a baptismal ceremony,
killing at least 14 and wounding 63
Christians. Indonesia, May 13, 2018.
Muslim terrorists bombed three churches,
killing 13 and injuring many. Egypt,
again, on New Year's Eve 2011, Muslim
terrorists bombed a packed church in
Alexandria during mass, killing 21.
Eyewitnesses reported bloody parts
strewn outside with some attackers
stepping on them and chanting Allah
Abbar. Philippines, January 27, 2019.
Muslim terrorists bombed a cathedral,
killing at least 20 and injuring over
100 Christians. Indonesia on Christmas
Eve 2000, bombings at several churches
killed a total of 18 and injured over
100 Christians. Bkino Faso again
February 25, 2024, Muslim gunmen stormed
a church, murdering 15 Christians.
Pakistan again March 15, 2015, Muslim
terrorists killed at least 14 Christians
in attacks on two churches. Germany.
December 19, 2016. Near Berlin's Kaiser
Vilhem Memorial Church, a Muslim man
drove a truck into a Christmas market,
killing 13 and injuring 55.
Egypt again. December 29, 2017. Muslim
gunman opened fire inside a Cairo
church, killing nine Christians. Egypt
again. Following Christmas Eve mass
2010, Muslims shot six Christians dead
as they exited church. Russia again.
February 18th, 2018. A Muslim attacker
armed with a knife and shotgun opened
fire in the church, killing five women
and wounding at least five more. France,
July 26, 2016. Muslims entered a church
and slit the throat of an 84 yearear-old
priest, Father Hamill, as he was
celebrating mass. Turkey, January 28,
2024. Two mass gunmen entered an
Istanbul church and opened fire, killing
only one man and injuring another. To be
clear, this list is far from exhaustive.
In Nigeria alone, Muslim extremists have
destroyed or torched roughly 20,000
churches and Christian schools, though
these are rarely cited on mainstream
media. One wonders how many thousands
have perished in these largely
unreported attacks. Moreover, the church
attacks I just listed exclude the many
failed terror attempts, such as the 2021
Palm Sunday attack on an Indonesian
church, where only the Muslim suicide
bombers died, a man and his pregnant
wife. or closer to home in the United
States. On April 6th, 2024, Alexander
Scott Mercurio, an 18-year-old convert
to Islam, was arrested for plotting a
suicide attack on multiple churches
scheduled for the following day in
Celane, Idaho. Authorities said he
planned to attack local places of
worship with knives, guns, and fire. Nor
does my list include the constant stream
of daily non-fatal attacks and
desecrations that plague churches,
especially in European regions with
large Muslim populations. Even so, based
on the very limited list of church
attacks and statistics I just shared,
Muslims have slaughtered well over 1,000
Christians who were otherwise peacefully
worshiping in their churches. Keep in
mind, I'm only talking about those
Christians killed in the context of
church attacks. A far greater number of
Christians have been killed by Muslims
outside of church and in general. Again,
in Nigeria alone, a Christian is
slaughtered every two hours. But I've
left these much greater numbers out to
create a perfect analogy between attacks
on mosques and attacks on churches. And
so, we come back full circle to that
most pressing of questions that demands
an answer. If a single non-Muslim attack
that killed 51 Muslims was enough for
the United Nations to establish an
international day to combat
Islamophobia, why have countless Muslim
attacks on churches, which have claimed
well over 1,000 Christian lives, meaning
roughly 20 Christians are killed in
their churches for every one Muslim
killed in a mosque, not been sufficient
for a similar response? Why has the UN
not created an international day to
combat Christianophobia? Put simply, why
does one isolated incident of a western
man killing 51 Muslims in two mosques
command far greater attention and
importance than the countless Muslim
attacks killing more than 1,000
Christians in their churches? This
question becomes even more urgent when
we consider that while the New Zealand
mosque attack was indeed a shocking
aberration, Muslim attacks on churches
are disturbingly common both
historically and today. Indeed, rarely
does a single week pass in the Muslim
world and increasingly in Western
countries without multiple assaults on
or harassments of churches. Furthermore,
consider this. The perpetrators of these
church attacks often share very little
in common. They come from different
countries, Nigeria, Iraq, the
Philippines, and beyond. They belong to
different races, speak various
languages, and live under vastly
different social, political, and
economic conditions. The only thing that
unites them, the only thing that fuels
their deadly assaults on churches and
Christian worshippers is their common
faith, Islam. And it is a faith that
unsurprisingly contains teachings
hostile towards churches and infidels.
Though this uncomfortable truth is also
widely suppressed. In short, Muslim
attacks on churches are ideologically
motivated. They have been and continue
to be systematic and widespread. They
represent a very real ongoing crisis
that the international community should
be confronting and addressing. Yet, the
United Nations prefers to dismiss all
those massacres of Christians and
attacks on churches as unfortunate
products of random terrorist groups that
have nothing whatsoever to do with and
have hijacked Islam. Instead, their full
focus, as seen, is locked onto a single
incident, a western man killing 51
Muslims. For the UN, that sole and
isolated incident reflects a pattern
that needs to be recognized and
responded to. And what in reality has
been the UN's response? To shut up and
silence all who dare connect the dots
and expose Islam's heavily documented
pattern of violence against non-Muslims,
which make no mistake is precisely what
combating Islamophobia is all about.